oh wait I want to talk about one other
thing we need to make sure we tell
people how to make money in a recession
fully understand the language of money
which is deal making and finance and
then you got to understand how do you
negotiate and then you've got to
understand yourself like that stuff
inside of you what do I really like
doing what makes me happy you pair that
with the fact that you guys have Tech at
your fingertips in a way that we never
did it's amazing you should be looking
at this environment like man now is the
time to lean in it's the time to build
it's the time to buy something it's the
time to partner with somebody to buy
something and no better time right now
than to do it all right guys bang bang
I'm here with Cody uh the world's going
to [ __ ] the entire economy is collapsing
how do we make money I like it I think
that is the question everyone's asking
themselves is they're watching stock
prices fall real estate is now cooling
off crypto has essentially imploded uh
just kidding and uh you know gotta give
a shout out to the faithful
um people are really worried and there's
a couple different reactions to people
say hey I don't want to invest at all
I'm just going to save my money and like
just wait till everything recovers but
then there's other people they see blood
in the streets and they're ready to go
what do you think is kind of the play
here or how do people make money during
a downturn yeah I think you're crazy to
do nothing so if I'm your audience I'm
freeing up some cash because I don't
think we're at the blood and the streets
level yet actually at all I think we're
just starting little drips and so in my
opinion the best way to do it and people
have maybe heard me say this before is
you want cash flowing businesses with
relatively low capex theoretically or an
ability to get debt or somebody else's
capital in order to plow a bunch of
money into things that you can raise
prices if there's inflation and where
people buy them no matter what for
instance do you know what I was doing
yesterday actually this isn't in my
notes we were in Tampa Florida at a
crime scene company this crime scene
cleanup company fascinating actually
they do 12 million dollars in Revenue a
year she's a former cop their margins
are 60 and what happens is if you decide
paulina's not gonna make it right
and and there's a crime scene at your
house right then sadly you think oh well
you know the cops come in they take the
body and they clean it up wrong
there's no such thing as a government
crime scene Cleanup in fact you have to
pay a private Enterprise to come and
clean up whatever messes there so
imagine there are meth labs fentanyl
Labs hoarders all of that costs money
and so if there's a meth lab cleanup
it's anywhere from twelve thousand to
fifty thousand dollars this lady comes
in cleans up the meth lab and makes
sixty percent profit margin do you have
to have special training to clean up the
uh and also not certifications isn't
that wild interesting so really it's
like no different than a moving company
right to some degree but it's specific
for uh cleaning up crime scenes yeah
like California you could imagine would
probably be stricter than Florida for
instance where you probably just throw
it over your back
um but uh moral of the story is I think
these type of boring businesses that's
recession resistant right like
unfortunately we all still die we all
still have crimes and so what I would do
is I would be looking for where is there
a business where there's something
boring dirty or sweaty that other people
don't want to do theoretically or don't
think about doing that have pretty high
margins so you make a pretty good amount
of cash on it it and you can give them
capital in a period where who's going to
go out and fund a crime scene cleanup
like you put that on Twitter it's not
going to get a bunch of VC Capital
that's where I would be putting my money
to work what are some other ideas that
you've seen where you're just like okay
crime scene cleanup is not something
most people have ever heard of before
are there other ones that you're like
this is incredible how these businesses
survive oh 100 well there's so many I
mean we filmed 30-ish videos thus far on
YouTube all about these what I call
boring businesses we have 130 boring
business lists on our website that talks
about every type of business that I
think would be interesting to own one of
the other ones I really like today
um that I'm looking at in a big way is
ice spending uh businesses I've seen you
talk about this I think we talked about
it one time before like why is ice
vending so good well one of the reasons
why I think it's interesting that I
hadn't thought of before is every time
you get into a deal I think you should
always think about how am I going to get
out of a deal because you might not want
to run an ice spending business forever
right and so with ice spending the cool
thing about this business it has my rule
of three which is basically a
reoccurring Revenue business that you
can bundle up consistently that has good
margins and so with ice vending machines
you can have subscriptions for these
types of businesses you have a high
repeat customer rates because they're
kind of doing the same activities that
they need are you spending for and then
it's also a low people high margin
business and so I like this one because
say you want to like go save the world
well why don't you start in a tough
neighborhood located in outside of Fort
Wayne Indiana where the water filtration
is actually pretty bad and so people
don't want to use ice out of their
refrigerators ever they want to go to a
ice vending machine and use the ice out
of the ice vending machine constantly
because you have better filtration
systems and so this one I think could
solve problems and you could do it in a
lot of communities where it's a cheap
product relatively but there's a huge
need for it and then PE companies like
these models because they can bundle
them up and and uh and sell them off and
so it feels like PE firms they used to
go do really really big deals then
there's kind of the Middle Market was
for Independence and they thought
there's some Arbitrage there are the PE
firms now getting either desperate or
see opportunity and going kind of
earlier and earlier as we're seeing
Venture Capital funds and even the
crossover hedge funds in the Venture
world go earlier and earlier like will
we see PE funds go and buy a business
now with like a million dollars in
revenue and try to scale it I don't
think traditional PE firms will do that
at a million bucks but I think there's a
bunch of people like you and I that you
know what's the difference between a
private Equity Firm and Warren Buffett
theoretically private Equity just means
you take somebody's money that is
private and you use it to buy businesses
typically outright or a large percentage
of them and then lbos leverage buyouts
you use some debt or something else to
apply to the business so I think private
Equity has really expanded used to just
be KKR and Carlisle on these guys now it
could be you or me right so now there
are micro PE guys like me that would go
in and say ah a million dollar Revenue
business
um I think we could do a bolt-on and
invest in another company on top of this
and this could be a nice little five
million dollar business that we
eventually sell off to somebody else
what I do think though for these big PE
firms is they're realizing increasingly
that some of these you know boring
Enterprises that they have historically
bought at 10 to 20 million dollars in
valuations they want to start tracking
earlier because it's so much more
competitive to get to the deal when it's
at 10 mil so you could start talking to
a PE firm like one of the ones we're
talking to for selling our car washes
when you only have five or six of them
and they're like hey the second you have
10 or 12 call me I want to be your first
call and then they'll buy them for two
to three times what I bought them for
because they're worth more as a sum
that's greater than its parts and when
they buy it they're buying it to you
because they think they can then go bolt
on from 10 to 12 to 20 30 40 50 and then
they'll turn around and they'll sell it
to kind of the next person in the
hierarchy of PE that's looking for 50 or
more car washes and you kind of just
continue and every three to five years
these companies get uh kind of
transitioned between the owners yeah
that's exactly right or you know a lot
of times they'll look at these small
businesses and say oh my gosh you guys
don't have reoccurring subscriptions
um you're using all of these people on
the back end we don't need any of them
when we add them to our you know model
so these guys are this isn't rocket
science but the models are relatively
sophisticated where they're like all
right uh right now you have 20 costs
that we're not going to have so we can
pay you a little bit more for it and
yours are worth only 5x when there's so
many of them because that's a job not a
business but when you add it to our
thing they're actually worth 6X because
now that makes our thing a business and
not a job from a revenue standpoint so
yeah that's exactly right and the game
isn't always bigger the game could just
be cash flow or the fact that PE funds
and you know all this but like maybe
people listening don't have seven to ten
year investment Cycles so at a certain
point I give you my money as a PE firm I
want that cash back and so after seven
or ten years you're like okay we've
three extra money now it's time to sell
this access for a premium and we close
the fund so naturally you have velocity
city of businesses which is not
necessarily a bad thing so most of the
boring businesses that we've talked
about in the past are all called in the
analog world in the real world right not
on the internet with the uh imaginary uh
kind of audience or uh activity but
there are companies uh we've seen
constellation software we've seen many
others uh Vista and others uh that buy
internet companies or buy software-based
companies are there companies that sit
at the intersection of boring businesses
and software that you find interesting
or is it all in the analog world I love
this question yeah we started a fund
basically with this entire method it
happened after actually we were talking
with some of the bigger Partners at
Vista who have since left and gone and
done other things because the founder of
Vista is actually the wealthiest black
dude in the country
um he's absolutely crushed it and their
motto was essentially you just take kind
of underperforming SAS companies right
and turn them around and sell them or
make them bigger and I thought gosh
that's really interesting I always think
of SAS companies like slack or YouTube
like they're never gonna sell the whole
business to you for you to turn around
and and
um and make better but there's a bunch
of these zombie SAS companies or these
you know underperforming tech companies
that you could take and turn around so
the two types of companies I think are
interested in uh in the tech world right
now are one that I actually bought we
bought one tiny little
um SAS company that essentially does
non-stop 24 7 uh chat engagement with
small business owners clients so I can
imagine like you want to go get your
lock changed like you're locked out of
your house you need somebody to respond
to you immediately most locksmiths do
not have that capacity our software
allows them to do that and there's a
real human that's connected with sort of
the AI and that allows them to Outsource
to a bunch of Locksmiths and the first
one to respond you know gets the
engagement side note real quick this is
a crazy detail about the city of Miami
uh anyone who lives in the high-rise
buildings uh in most of the situations
if you get locked out of your apartment
uh you cannot go to the management
office and like get a key you have to
call a locksmith so there's like
multiple buildings I know this is true
and uh it's happened to me one time and
uh called locksmith he was there in like
20 minutes he literally came not with
like your normal like lock picking tools
he literally came with what looked
almost like a uh a hanger like a like a
a um kind of a malleable hanger but it
was a specially built he put it
underneath the door he flipped it up and
he yanked on it and all he did was on
the inside he just grabbed the door
handle and he pulled it and the door
opened and he turned him he goes that'd
be 150 bucks and I was like haha how
much is it he was like no it's 150 and I
was like what and he was like yeah he's
like normally if uh we have to pick the
lock it's like 250 or 200 or whatever
the number was uh but if we just use
this tool then it's only like 150. and I
was like you spent less than three
minutes in front of the door and it just
reminded me it's like you don't get paid
for the time he's spending now you get
paid for the fact that he has the
knowledge to build the tool to show up
to like do the whole thing and I was
like man I miss you locksmiths are
amazing business oh amazing well it's
like that Paolo Picasso story where like
the lady comes up to ask him for a
painting and he takes out a napkin and
he draws like a scribble on it and hands
it to her and says that'll be ten
thousand dollars and she's like what are
you talking about took you 20 seconds
and he was like no no that took me 10
years but like this last part took me 20
seconds and so I think you're right A
lot of these service businesses have all
this inherent knowledge
um and and a lot of them actually don't
know how to price it that well
interesting it's one of my favorite
Parts about buying these companies think
about them every single small business
is Costco with their hot dogs right like
they haven't changed the price in 472
years and they haven't even considered
it because they're doing okay they're
like happy they're mowing along but for
you to get your lock changed in a
high-rise in Miami you'd probably pay
300 bucks because are you going to sleep
outside like no you're not you're going
to pay whatever the guy tells you and
it's a last minute need and so
um so my my point with this conversation
is
these small businesses this one that we
bought for instance I bought it for
sixty thousand dollars so not a big
investment
um relatively and this business was
doing about 40K in profit a year but no
marketing atrocious website and we
basically took this company put a better
better website on it gave it a few
different lines of Revenue and now the
company will do a couple hundred K in
revenue and that's like that Vista
little model take something sort of
zombie make it slightly better in Tech
and how did you find this company I got
this from the best ways I get deals
probably the same for you why do I do
the internet stuff because people send
me interesting stuff so this one this
one guy forever ago reached out to me on
Twitter DMS uh I became friends with him
he runs a business he was like I found
the software that I use for my business
it's amazing this guy's older he's ready
to retire I think we could buy it I'll
run it for you like perfect how much
money let's draft up the docs and now
we've done two deals uh with this guy's
name John Shadow John
um and when you do that deal you go in
you look at the business how do you
evaluate whether it's a good business or
not like one is do you how like why do
you trust John to run the business and
then two like how do you know that okay
paying 60 is a good price but paying 100
might not be but uh you know 75 would be
you know iffy yeah well for that small
of a deal so a couple different things
one your first deal should never
bankrupt you right so if you're
listening to this and 60k is a lot of
money maybe your first deal is 6k
because you're going to make your some
mistakes for the first one you and I are
probably the same in that we've had a
lot of reps at this and so it's like how
do you hit a ball with a bat you're like
well you like put it back here and then
you kind of turn and then you follow
through whatever and so it's the same
with doing deals I think my first deal I
did everything wrong you know I overpaid
for the first deal you know I ran it
myself it was a job not a business but
now I look at basically five key things
one is will it bankrupt me two is does
it have enough cash flow for me to be
meaningful so I don't want to do a deal
if it's going to make me 2K a year it's
probably not worth it you figure out
your own own metric three is this
business am I paying a multiple on
profits then it's anywhere from two to
five x that's just what I pay for small
businesses so that's really easy and
means that you don't have to screen out
a bunch of extra stuff because I know
for a small business I can get my money
back in two years it's a pretty low risk
and then the next one is like is it
really simple do I understand the
business are they saying the word
proprietary that I'm running you know
anything why because I don't I'm not
intelligent enough to run a biotech
company with proprietary XYZ that does
all of this I want like I call it sows
which is simple old weak and stale
businesses I want them to be super
simple to understand around for a while
so that I know they're going to continue
to stay around week competition nobody
else is playing and stale and that like
this website sucked there was no
marketing so I don't have to be the best
deal maker because the business is so
much upside optimization so that's how
you know when you look at the business
is usually you're negotiating a purchase
price with someone who has an emotional
attachment to the business as well uh
how do you negotiate in a way that
doesn't offend them doesn't feel like
you're calling their child ugly but at
the same time you can negotiate well
enough to get a price that makes sense
for you yeah that's a good point I
usually don't make it about their
business I say something like this
um
hey pomp uh you know your business is
really interesting I'd love to talk to
you about it I buy businesses at two to
five x profits which is what the
industry multiple is for a business like
yours I'm interested in discussing a
little bit further um here's sort of a
link explaining what current multiples
are and I send them to a link to This
research report from Biz Buy sell which
is the largest aggregator of small
business data and then I say something
like if it might be interesting to you
to talk about selling at the right price
and terms I'd love to have discussion
but I've already set the floor and the
ceiling really like here's kind of where
I go and I've established this isn't me
this is the market so and I haven't said
your business is only worth two hundred
thousand dollars even though you've
slaved your life for it I've said hey
this is what business is or it works so
you remove the emotional attachment with
that it's the plan at least uh I
invested in micro acquire the um I think
it's similar to biz buys uh what is it
called Biz by cell Biz by cell uh micro
acquire I know
um and I haven't bought a business off
of there when you go on and you look are
there certain things that are red flags
to you yeah there's really easy ones
there'll be a ton of them on these sites
not micro acquire micro acquire does a
pretty good job of scrubbing the
businesses they're all online businesses
not these like brick and mortar ones
that I sometimes buy but um you don't
want any business that's a franchise or
startups those websites are littered
with people that are like oh you can
start this it's not a business it has to
be profitable it has to be cash flowing
second for these businesses you want to
make sure that there's real profits in
the business and so a lot of times
they'll say things like
um you know ten thousand dollars in
profits you know you can run with this
local vending machine route but then
they won't put in the seller's
discretionary earnings okay what you
make to run this so in in that instance
you don't want to buy a business where
you're getting paid 10K a year to run it
probably
um so that's the second thing and then
the third is just lots of people are
going to tell you like yeah by the way I
my tax returns don't exactly match my P
L's right and and you just have to say
hey man I buy on tax returns for my
first deal I can't [ __ ] around on like
trying to figure out if your P L's are
right or not once you get a little bit
more sophisticated you could dig in you
could do things like coin counts on
laundromats or car washes but for your
first deal you're like I buy based on a
profit multiple of the tax returns so
those are the three biggest items have
you ever seen uh tax returns that are
better than the p l no funny how that
happens no I'm willing to say if you're
gonna cheat Uncle Sam like all right you
got me yeah but that's probably it
um when you think of the types of
businesses many of the businesses that
you've mentioned they don't have a lot
of people and I think this is really
fascinating
um we've got a bunch of mutual friends
that uh I think a lot of people are like
hey technology the internet software uh
but also traditional businesses people
are figuring out how to do more with
less people uh what have you seen there
that's like super interesting today's
episode is brought to you by ftxus
they're a safe regulated way to buy
Bitcoin and cryptocurrencies they've got
very cheap fees sometimes as much as 85
percent cheaper than their competitors
there's also no minimum fees there's no
withdrawal fees or any other hidden fees
ultimately FTX us is trying to make it
dead simple for you to buy Bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies they also now have
digital stock trading as well with no
transaction fees and no payment for
order flow all you have to do is go
download the FTX app today from the App
Store and use code pop and you'll get
some money back every single time you
trade 10 or more again Go download the
FTX app today use code pop and every
time you trade 10 or more they'll go
ahead and they'll give you some crypto
back the more you trade the more you
earn download the FTX app today yeah
well I love high margin low people
businesses I think there's two there's
like two caveats man right I mean the
first thing you know this too people
like I'd like to make 200k in passive
income by sitting around and I have no
cash like how should we do it it's like
nah dude get a job get a job man Jesus
like that's I don't know drive from
Walmart you get 100K it's like the
second you figure that out call me man
because I'd love to know but uh so like
not that that's always by the way that's
never somebody with tons of experience
says that it's always the 18 to 22 year
old kid who watched Tick Tock yeah
exactly exactly 100 100 so like
like so that's not
or a ton of
Biz that I like to call I think I think
it bonds you know how you buy Equity
because you think Equity is going to go
up and it's going to make you a bunch of
money there's a lot of businesses that
are bonds like a I don't know a
laundromat's a good example like a
laundromat is never going to be worth 50
million dollars right like I don't care
what you do with it paint it you know
put glow sticks on it not gonna be worth
50 million dollars and so that type of
business is relatively passive because
you don't have to have an operator all
the time you're not going to try to grow
the business uh exponentially you use
the labor of the equipment as opposed to
your own labor and it has a model that's
kind of done it continuously and so
there are a bunch of businesses like
this like car washes laundromats ice
vending machines anything that's Machine
Heavy can often be relatively passive
but don't get me wrong like you're gonna
at some point have somebody call and say
like you know my XYZ inappropriate sex
object got caught in your laundromat you
know and then you're gonna have to fish
it out so there's always going to be
these like weird things where you
actually have to
and the machines break right so there's
always like the the whole uh you have to
service the actual things doing the work
um but also I do think it's interesting
uh that you can meld some of these
businesses together and mold them
together
um and so uh gas stations yeah are uh
very interesting to me is it a gas
station or is a convenience store and
like it kind of depends sometimes
depending on how many pumps do they have
how much foot traffic do they get you
know are they actually selling more food
or gas like all this stuff but then
inside of the convenience store uh I've
seen something like pretty crazy
Innovative things there's obviously hey
we'll rent you you know a two by two
space on the floor and you can put your
ATM or your uh crypto machine or
whatever but then you see like what
about the lottery devices that are in
there and that's just renting space uh
almost kind of like wework did but for
convenience stores where they take one
space cut it up and rent it out but then
you start to see them doing even more
things so you go into a convenience
store and they realize where they are is
a really special location and so I
recently went into a convenience store
and they had all kinds of crazy merch
and I was like what is going on here and
I realized that they were right at the
intersection of two state lines or a
state line between two states and there
was tons of tourist traffic that went
back and forth and it was like last
second before you leave the state if you
happen to stop here and you want to get
that gift
buy it here at the gas station oh I like
that and so I asked the person I said
hey you know how much of that did you
sell and they were like that's we sell
more of that than anything in this store
and I was like wow that makes so much
sense and it reminded me what do they do
at airports if you go to Miami Airport
all the stores every single piece of
clothing in that store uh is Miami
something why because people who are
landing or people who are leaving let me
get my Miami you know uh uh kind of um
merchandise and so it does make you
think a lot about like if you ran like a
convenience store like what are all the
things you could do within that square
footage that could make more money and
then if you ask yourself like how many
of those people actually are doing that
stuff my guess is probably very few of
them because they're family businesses
they've been around for a while whatever
uh and so it begs the question like if a
bunch of young people come in and buy
these assets like are we going to see
like a revitalization and kind of all
new business models with some of these
uh businesses and these properties a
hundred percent I have two fats so first
of all the gas station yes the
fascinating part about gas stations are
they make no money on gas the margins on
gas I can't remember it's like three
cents again now it's ridiculous how
little money they make on gas the play
is just to get you into their ecosystem
and then they've got the car wash over
there and then they've got the air pump
over there and they charge you 50 cents
for air like that's probably a pretty
good business so like all those things
with car washes are interesting I mean
with gas stations are interesting I
don't like owning gas stations because
talk about inventory like could you even
imagine just going into those things
stresses me out with the amount of stuff
that they've got in there now it could
probably all survive a nuclear
apocalypse apocalypse because no fresh
food but for the most part like that's
not a great business in my mind for a
newbie
um the interesting part about gas
stations in general though I think are
that they do what you talked about
really well which is just Revenue stream
adding for your business so I'm really
big on okay
when you buy a business you buy it for
the profits that's it I don't want to
hear your story about you could do X and
Y and Z and I'm going to pay for your
the X and Y and Z that you haven't done
nope I buy the business for what you've
done but then in the back of my head not
talking to the seller I'm like oh okay
well what if we added the car wash here
well what if we added the air freshener
you know distribution box over here well
what if we put ads on top of X Y and Z
so we get that reoccurring digital
Revenue all of those things I think are
just like you think about let me add a
little Apple stock let me add a little
Amazon stock and I want to have a
diversified portfolio you want your
business to have that too especially for
these small businesses so 100 but to
your point on you know kids taking over
old school businesses you know you guys
your audience probably is not gonna
remember this do you remember that movie
uh You've Got Mail yeah right so when
you got mail got mail yeah exactly you
nailed it um so they have uh they had
this woman who owned a little bookstore
and then like evil tongue Hanks Barnes
Noble comes in and like kills her
bookstore and I remember watching that
business and now I think about what I do
today I'm like you know I love making
money most of what I do is because I
think the game of money is fun but also
like [ __ ] Starbucks like wouldn't it be
nice it if on every street corner there
wasn't a Walmart a Starbucks a CVS like
I go through all these little towns all
around the world last week we're in
chicolote Ohio I'm like a lot of them
starting to look the same I'm not into
that and so wouldn't it be better if
that little bookstore if instead of her
trying to like fight the man with like
her limited skill set as somebody who
would run this business for 10 20 years
she brought in a young gun and guess
what that young gun would have done
probably maybe they would have figured
out Amazon first they would have done an
actual online bookstore component maybe
they would have done subscriptions
instead maybe they would have added a
coffee shop or a bar and so instead of
these businesses having to go under
because they can't compete or the owners
are tired they get new revitalized
energy and so that's why I'm a really
big component for like young people
listening okay fine yeah go work at
slack for a while get real skills go
work at a big company for a while get
real skills but after a minute as
opposed to building somebody else's
house or somebody else's Castle why
don't you build your own and hey by the
way wouldn't it be better if you did it
in like a community Unity where you
could touch something and you could
create something every day I think
that'd be pretty cool and we'd probably
like our communities and our country a
little bit better if we had less
Walmarts and more corner stores I have
some ideas of businesses I'd love to run
through with you let's do it uh coffee
shops I've always thought someone should
create a membership-based coffee shop
that was specifically structured and
designed for business meetings oh I like
that yeah how many times have you gone
to a coffee shop and you're like I don't
want this weirdo listening to my
conversation or I was talking about X
and now you know Sally over here thinks
that she has an opinion on uh whatever
and I literally had one time a uh uh
experience where I was talking about uh
something some tech company or whatever
and there was a gentleman sweetest guy
in the world I frankly think he was
lonely and next thing I know I'm like oh
I'm having a meeting with two people not
with one because he just kept talking
and like and interjecting and all stuff
and I was like I would love to just be
able to meet someone that isn't in an
office or isn't in my home and be able
to have coffee meet quickly and leave
and do it with some degree of privacy it
doesn't mean there's got to be some
soundproof room or whatever but like you
can imagine you go in and there's like
little booths and it's just optimized
for people are going to come here do
business meetings and leave
why would you not pay a couple hundred
dollars per month to get coffee
unlimited and be able to meet in peace
yeah well I think you know the cool
thing about a business like that is how
I like to play this game my husband and
I do it all the time it's like all right
let's come up with an idea like that now
and then we do like the Xanax Matrix
which I didn't come up with but like
um but basically it's you know four
boxes and each box it's like why should
you do it why shouldn't you do it what
are the costs what are the benefits and
I like to take that box and then overlay
it with how could we make this work and
how could we make this awesome and so
the box for that might be like all right
we want to have a coffee business
meeting place so like Soho house but not
awful service and totally overpriced and
a bunch of hipster douchebags and also
you know like coffee that tastes good
and is a little hipster but the things
good for for recording podcasts how
would we make it work you got a
subscription model maybe you also have
an e-commerce component maybe you get
some sponsors because you know the
sponsors are going to want to be in
front of these business owners so you
get like slack to give you free XYZ you
get like X person to give you so then
you start to like kind of go down the
list how else could we make this
business a huge FPS instead of a maybe
and I don't think enough business owners
do that and so if you're a young gun
coming into these some of these
businesses you're like I want to own a
car wash okay cool how could you own a
car wash and make it amazing and not
amazing like I think this is a cool
really car wash to go to but amazingly
profitable and so in that instance for
me for a car wash I'd be like I want to
add a vending machine I want to add one
of those walls like in Austin where it's
like I love tacos so much and everybody
lines up and they take pictures at it
and then right by that I might have a
vending machine and because I know a
bunch of young people are going to come
around that vending machine might have
stuff that they want to buy immediately
and then maybe I'd have like automated
air freshener dispensers and so you
layer on all of this stuff and that's
how you turn these boring businesses
into something cool so you mentioned uh
the walls the other thing that I think
it would be an amazing business is to
reimagine uh remember when you were a
kid and your parents would like take you
to like a professional for photographer
on like some like stupid Milestone yeah
I have four brothers so you can imagine
the five of us and they were like trying
to put us like okay you sit here you lay
on the ground here whatever where are
these
we just beat the [ __ ] out of each other
and like people Somebody's Crying
somebody's like this my mom's like just
take the picture and the photographer is
just literally snapping away like I hope
I got one
um imagine today with Instagram and all
this stuff like actually the
photographer component of it is not
nearly as important as like the sets and
like all the stuff and we saw um I think
it's the ice cream Museum yeah or
whatever like it's just people have
tried this at uh they've tried like a
really big scale but like how many
people between the ages of like I don't
know 25 and 40 who have young kids would
love to take them somewhere and have
like 40 or 50 different backgrounds and
kind of set designs that they would love
to just take photos on their phone and
if they can just take photos on their
phone now all of a sudden you don't have
to pay the photographer you don't have
to do any of the equipment you don't
have to like do all the things that they
used to do after the photo was taken
it's just literally like hey I just
hired the people paying me to now be the
photographer and they brought their own
kids thankfully and so like half at it
and all you're doing is you're paying
rent and then the cost set it up oh I
love that yeah maybe you had pets too
because you know people are psychopaths
with their pets so I have a little pet
component to us I'm into it actually our
I think you know them too but Alex
formosi has a business uh that they
invested in that's like uh it's a
photography it's a photography studio
and he said they do millions of dollars
a year it's a franchise photography
studio and I think there is a mixture of
in person and you know self-selected
whatever I mean even I'm here with with
my videographer and photographer and
like half the time I'm like yeah God I
really need to go on and take these
headshots and like run in for XYZ but
there's no like where are you running in
and so yeah I'm on board I think it's a
good idea the um the the other component
of this uh around pets wildest that of
2022 I heard there are 78 million dogs
in America and there's like 73 million
children under the age of 18. so there
are more dogs than there are children
under the age of 18 in the United States
well you have a kid are you really
surprised now I feel like you could have
like a few more dogs but like throw a
few kids and that's a commitment man
it's but like think about that like the
dog Market is bigger than the kids
Market yeah I agree well and I mean the
thing about dogs is at least as far as
I'm aware you can't like throw your dog
in the or your kid in the trunk and like
leave them there for a while and they're
still excited to see you you know I
think there's like some other parameters
but um actually we have this this mutual
friend Ramon we focused on his company
Alpha Pet in one of our YouTube videos
amazing he bought the I'm gonna mess up
the numbers sorry Ramon but let's say
you bought the business for like
10 or 50k or if you bought another
business and then added this one onto it
but he bought the business for nothing
and now they're doing tens of millions
of dollars in revenue and his little
hack that I loved was don't Market to
dogs make specific Facebook groups for
like wiener dogs and then for I don't
know cavapoos and whatever and make
branded food and branded treats and
branded toys and whatever that are
probably a lot of the same thing but for
each type of dog because people are so
crazy about breeds of dogs that that's
like one of the biggest Revenue drivers
for his business jump start third grade
uh the old CD-ROMs that you could go buy
at uh like the Learning Center or
whatever oh yeah remember they used to
for all you young kids they literally
used to sell CD-ROMs with software on
them that you would use
um and so uh there was jumpstart
software and if I remember the details
correctly they had uh like Elementary
School software and it was going okay
but the big breakthrough was they made
it for third grade and all the parents
in the second grade bought it because
they're like my kid's not going to pass
third grade unless they have the third
grade software and so then they went to
second grade and first grade in
kindergarten and then fourth grade fifth
grade sixth grade and what they actually
did was they drastically increased the
number of skus that they were able to
sell and they increased the throughput
of each one of those individual skus and
the business exploded and so it's the
specialization uh and the specific uh
targeting ended up actually making the
whole business there's so many riches
and niches I know people all the time I
like to think like don't tell me what to
do I don't like to get told what to do I
want to be free I want to do whatever I
want and then the second in a business
I'm like no no actually these are your
bumper lines and stay in it you actually
make so much more money and are so much
happier I mean we have an education
business that talks about buying
businesses now and uh what we found is
we have a buying Business course and
that does well but we also have a course
on laundromats specifically and we have
one on online businesses and we have one
on car washes and the the difference is
problem aware versus solution aware and
so for problem aware people like hey I
want to make more money because I don't
want to work at this job forever but I
don't have an idea and I don't want to
do a startup I'd like to buy a business
because uh you know I'm I'm interested
in that maybe that person is just
problem aware they don't really want to
buy a car wash they don't want to buy a
laundromat so their intention to buy is
so much lower than somebody who's like I
want to buy a car wash so this Niche
which is so much smaller sells so much
more because they're problem aware these
guys in solution aware State basically
we just have to give them more ways to
figure out what they want to do and they
won't buy the you know generalized
courses as much and we see this you know
now I have I have a lot of businesses
and so across businesses once I realize
this I'm like oh my gosh where are where
are we selling to people that are not
actually problem where they're just a
solution where where are we getting a
lot of attention but they don't have the
intention to actually execute and then
simultaneously
where do we have businesses where you
know people are thinking about ideas but
not actually moving forward towards
towards execution and we need to move
out of those you have been creating a
ton of content on the internet and uh
it's going very well uh I know that
you've talked with night media who
manages Mr Beast uh and it sounds like
you agree and disagree with some of the
decisions that they've made in the past
uh so I'd love to understand like how do
you think about the content you're
creating why are you doing it and then
like why are you independent versus
signing with someone and do you consider
signing with someone or do you want to
stay independent yeah
um first of all love the guys at night
media so no shame and like they're like
Giant and all over the Internet and have
way more they're rich people can
critique their strategy yeah plus I
become butts with them one lives down
the street for me so shout out Ben I'll
give you a hard time
um so one of the things I think is
really cool that the future is going to
we've already seen it is that
um everybody's gonna be a Content
business in some way and all my
companies that don't get this I'm trying
to get them to see it whether they're a
pressure washer company or a roofing
company like make content even if it's
just to get reviews
um and night media I think is seeing
this in that they're able to sell
something like Mr Beast chocolate bar to
his audience and make millions and
millions of dollars what I think is
interesting though is I really am
particular about the type of businesses
that I want to engage in if I'm going to
create something new now they sold Mr
BEAST's audience chocolate bars because
who watches Mr Beast 10 to 15 year olds
that's his target audience I had no idea
they were that young but that's why his
thumbnails are really bright that's why
it's very like action oriented not stop
think about how Mr Beast dresses right
it's kind of child bike in a way even
though he's not a child he's very smart
so they sold him chocolate bars which is
okay but the problem is
you are have a business which one is a
uh you know a business where the the
product after a certain period dies
right it becomes unable to be eaten
anymore two you don't have a reoccurring
Revenue model in that business
whatsoever three it's a highly
competitive Marketplace for that
business for how many kids these days do
you see buying chocolate bars and eating
them part of their normal life like
people don't really buy and eat
chocolate bars you might buy and eat
like individual bits of candy and so in
my mind what's going to happen in the
future is if if they were smart they
would have said all right we're gonna
buy we're gonna we're gonna buy rights
to a video game and we're gonna have a
business that is a reoccurring
subscription model because there will be
new iterations to your point on the
third grade fourth grade fifth grade
CD-ROM we're gonna have a business that
has reoccurring purchase price points
that we build once and get to sell
continuously you don't have to keep
building the video game to do it and
simultaneously where we get to be
through somebody's life cycle with them
so you can have video game one and then
as they get older they can kind of
upgrade to varying things plus you can
have add-on purchases so you could have
a Mr Beast video game consult you could
have a Mr Beast bean bag and all these
things could be third party produced
just like a lot of the Kardashians stuff
is and so it's white labeled product but
it is for that target audience and
allows you to build those additional
revenue streams around them so I think
in the future people are going to get so
much smarter about the products that
they build and you will no longer see
like a Mr Beast burger or a Mr Beast
chocolate bar is a really hard business
to create so I would pick something that
you have a lot more opportunity to build
once and sell continuously
do you think right now they're in the
startup Studio mode yeah are they going
to become a private Equity Firm they're
going to start buying uh these
businesses yeah I mean I talked to their
head of private Equity they they just
launched a 100 million dollar fund with
tpg capital the woman who's running it
her name's Alex she's super smart and I
think that's exactly what they're doing
they're going out and they're buying
companies and then going to pair them up
with big influencers which I actually
think is is really really smart if you
do the riots deals
um and and you know and the guys that
run it Ezra and Ben are super
intelligent like their backgrounds are
impressive I think they'll get more into
software like I've been telling them
listen you know and I think they'll get
into business influencers too which is
what I'm talking to them about but you
have Mr Beast giant audience you know
Cody little tiny audience but but my
audience the average uh viewer follower
of me you know 60 of our audience is
accredited right so they they have some
cash to throw around they have super
high intention you know my audience size
spends a lot of money either with me or
in investing and so if I'm looking at
creators just like I'm looking at
businesses I'm looking for okay who has
the highest Roi on each individual
purchase in order for me to want to
partner with them because maybe one you
know user for me could be worth a
hundred thousand dollars in lifetime
value and so all of this to say you know
this world that we're living in today it
started with a bunch of influencers you
know selling gummy bears and like skinny
teas you know for abs that they got in
the gym right and where it's going to
end up is private Equity firms and
software companies built on the back of
creators now it's gonna there's gonna be
a lot of stuff that goes wrong in the
middle but that's my my plan Kim
Kardashian is this real or is this all
[ __ ] that's I never thought if it
was [ __ ] I think it's real I mean I
do too as well yeah I think it's real
and I think they're really smart I mean
the part that killed me is like if you
guys like look online the screenshot of
her Instagram the day that it launched
it was like American flag ass pick
uh PE announcement Kim Kardashian second
one titties Kim Kardashian right like it
was just like right in between the two
and yeah that is Kim Kardashian that is
why I think she's gonna be president of
the United States I love you too because
I was like it's actually perfect it's
like who could pull that attention grab
this attention grab and I also think
it's important that uh she did it in
reverse like imagine if somebody had
risen to a position of power influence
and high success and then the sex tape
came out yeah it doesn't work right it
pulls you down so what you actually have
to do is sex tape first yeah reality TV
star business person
criminal justice
and then your Governor yeah that's our
advice for all of you listeners start
with the sex tape if you're gonna have a
sex tape do when no one knows who you
are yeah like for sure yeah yeah 100 do
you see the congressman or maybe not
Congressman but the person who's running
I think for Congress or Senate I think
it was in New York he created a sex tape
to show that he was uh in support of sex
workers no yeah sometimes some days I'm
like we live in a video game this is not
real there's no chance like I I just I
can't even like who who sat down in the
kitchen in the campaign room and was
like you know what we should do you
should create a sex tape and then we'll
tell people that you support sex workers
well we were just talking about I mean
that that I don't think is his brightest
idea but I'd love to meet him I think
that sounds like I could sell him
something else unbelievable but the
other thing we were just talking about
before this was like you should tell
that Elon Musk sinks story because I
didn't does everybody know that have you
already talked about that we haven't
talked about it but uh basically Elon
walks into uh the Twitter headquarters
uh two days before I think the deal got
finalized and uh he's carrying like a
big ceramic uh sink and he tweeted it
and said entering Twitter HQ let that
sink in and it's like uh admittedly I
just jumped to Bloomberg interviewed him
and they asked him would you rather be a
billionaire or a meme Lord and of course
the billionaires says a meme Lord and so
like it takes a sense of humor but like
actually what a great way to break the
ice with a bunch of people who think
that you're literally showing up with
like a virtual flamethrower and you're
gonna fire them all
okay x a new race car maybe
but actually no okay X is one of the
world's leading crypto trading apps okay
X
it's amazing well the other thing we
were talking about is you know at some
point you start to make a little bit of
money and then you feel pretty
comfortable at least with life I don't
think you ever like lose that oh my God
I could lose it all at any moment
they're gonna find out but but in some
ways it's like you want to have fun when
you run these businesses you know we
were just out at a car wash in in Ohio
and I was talking to the owner
um of it we were running through their
business and I'm like all right now I'm
gonna wrap you in this hose and we're
going to talk about like what could suck
about getting like stuck within your car
wash it was like okay you know I'll do
that I'm like listen the reason we have
businesses is because it's fun to grow
and it's a fun game but we don't have to
take life that seriously and also by the
way it's pretty fun running businesses
like it's not fun if you have to wear a
suit and tie every day like I did when I
was doing the Goldman Sachs Investment
Banking thing and you have to pretend to
be some
suit but at some point you know you get
to run your own business and then why
not make it entertaining for your
customers and the people that work for
you and that's the goal I need to like
bring a sink more places I have a theory
about a lot of the investment Banks uh
it is the most aspirational safe path
that you can take and so uh the people
who go and do that majority not all
there are outliers but majority of them
end up not going and actually starting
businesses because the path and the
thought process that it takes to go do
that for the most part will preclude you
from being able to stomach the risk that
it takes to go start and it also is
um uh JC's got this line he says uh
we're Corner boys with Corner offices
right and it's like really the
difference between the street the
boardroom strategy yeah uh so you're an
outlier in that like you were able to go
do that but still we're able to kind of
like break out of the Matrix you know
whatever you want to think about it and
be like wait a second like I actually
want to practice this myself not just be
a point in this big machine that is
doing this yeah our firm is doing it but
like are you really doing it if you're
just the person who's putting together
the numbers or the deck oh yeah kind of
not really right no well and it's the
golden handcuffs too you know you start
making some money you can make some good
money in that space and then you're like
all right I gotta go do a startup and
pay for me to maybe one day eventually
make money that's crazy town and so I do
get that the other thing is I think do
you get it though yeah I don't
understand it because like
I know people who are actively like
every day and I'm like you are not happy
doing what you are doing right like to
some degree like imagine loving money
so much that you are willing to do
things that you're unhappy doing with on
a day-to-day basis yeah I mean I think
it's hard for you and I to stomach it
because we've gotten past it but you
know if you think about most humans in
the U.S what's the truth we're
overweight we're unhappy we're on
prescription pills we don't have wealth
and we're divorced increasingly and not
having sex as a society so like human
nature today at least is like massively
path of least resistance and largely
unhappy and so while you and I I think
probably don't we don't contemplate life
that way and it gives us existential
angst to ponder the idea of living
inside of a cubicle with somebody else's
rules over us constantly other people
somehow have been wrapped up by Society
to think that that is okay to live that
way and I want to make a clear
distinction between like there's some
people who they have no other choice
right right like like if you're in a
situation where you're like I got
student debt I have a family I have like
all these things in like literally we
need to make money in order to eat yeah
that's a completely different story than
the people who like if you're making 250
000 you're working at an investment bank
and you're unhappy like you have and
you've been there for five years like
you're a [ __ ] idiot if you do not
have money in the bank to be able to
quit your job for six months and go try
something else yeah right like you you
have either uh partied too much you have
made some really bad financial decisions
done too many drugs like there's
something that happened in your life
that got you in a position where you've
made 1.25 million dollars over the last
five years and you've got nothing left
to be able to quit your job for six
months oh my God I mean well I trigger
these guys all the time on on Twitter
because you know it's like crabs in a
bucket so you know you start to make the
cash and then you see somebody that like
starts explaining like yeah we're not
doing rocket science it's two and twenty
we put together some models we get some
Bank debt we think that this business
looks profitable we buy it we sell like
it's not actually that intelligent and
when you start saying that people start
losing their minds because they have
their identity wrapped up and being a
banker bro right and so um I think this
happens all the time I try to shake it
up a little bit everybody gets pissed at
me on the internet but I think at the
end of the day there's my a little boy
inside a bunch of these dudes that is
like scared they're like oh my God
people are gonna find out I don't know
how to run a business people are going
to find out all I do investment banking
is make debt uh decks people are going
to find out that like yeah I'm like I
don't work out because I don't have time
I haven't seen the sun in 72 years you
know like I'm at Tao every night with my
sparklers but like I'm pretty much dying
on the inside and I think that's what a
lot of them are
um and so I mean Tau what a shout out
you know you don't know all about that
in crypto that was your guys's moment
for a while but yeah I think those guys
increasingly like I almost feel bad for
them because I think even making 250k
there's nothing more miserable than a
please fix this PowerPoint I I have a
framework uh there's actually a lot of
these folks who are in their mid-20s who
uh I'm not like a mentor to them but
like we talk and it's asking my opinions
about certain career decisions or
whatever and I always tell them uh it's
the 10-year sign on the dotted line
framework and all it means is if you do
the same thing for 10 years and you're
never responsible for signing on the
line for the deal then like you're not
doing deals so if you're 22 I don't care
who you are unless you're a huge outlier
you're not gonna be signing for the deal
right uh if you're 25 still unlikely if
you're 28 still okay maybe you're
starting to get you know high enough in
the organization if you're 32 years old
you've been somewhere for 10 years in an
industry and you're still not the
decision maker on I don't care if it's
the smallest deal that the firm does all
year long
but like something
is putting you on a trajectory where
like if you haven't done it in 10 years
what makes you think you're gonna do it
in 12 or 14 or 16 or 20. and so in 10
years you got to have the ability to
sign on the dotted line somewhere
because if you don't you never will yeah
100 and that's why like for people like
this it's like man go to something that
matters you know get get out of uh you
know New York every seven seconds
traveling to The Hamptons like leave the
deal sleds behind and instead you know
in my opinion like go go take that brain
you have which is probably pretty
intelligent if you're able to analyze
all of these numbers and if you're doing
anything in finance and like buy a small
business you know or go start something
on the side and Do It For the Love of it
not just for the cash and I you know I
think what will end up happening is
they'll realize man I thought it was a
deal junkie in Investment Banking but
turns out I'm just a deal junkie in
general and I actually might like to
build something and so rehab right the
other piece that I always say to them is
uh how much does your boss's boss make
yeah yeah and what ends up happening is
like these people like some of them are
making you know 150 to 300 000 then
they'll kind of jump up to 500 700 000
then you'll get kind of like vpmd levels
that now sudden you're making a million
dollars million and a half dollars right
I'm like okay oh that's cool like how
much does your boss's boss make and uh
usually there's like a million dollar
Milestone there's like a five million
and then the leap from five is to like
50. right like there's no like
difference between five and seven no
right it is literally inside this
organizations like you make a million
you make five and then it's like
unlimited and what I always explain to
them is like if you stay there for too
long
you're capped at five because you the
person who makes five at that same
organization never makes unlimited right
because they are in a different seat and
so uh you have to put yourself in a
position if you you desire again some
people just don't want to do it right
but if you desire to be in an unlimited
earnings seat then you have to get out
of the like track that you're in and to
your point like it is scary right like
actually in some way the earlier that
you rip the Band-Aid off the better off
you are because you're too stupid yeah
yeah exactly like you're literally too
dumb to realize this is a bad decision
yeah and so you just do it and then you
realize oh I'll just like figure it out
oh 100 well and I think you know the
other thing is like we're not talking
about dying here like nobody's dying
nobody's dying and like if you're in
these positions you're probably never
going homeless like we're actually in
this amazingly lucky situation and so
how can we do something really cool with
what we got I always loved that was it
Hemingway I think his quote was like I
wanna uh you know end up at the end of
my day it is in front of the Pearly
Gates like battered beaten and um you
know and totally used up I don't want to
be like clean and ready to go and I
think that's sort of the point of life
uh and why I like doing some hard things
also like when people need to get in the
gym man just like lift some heavy stuff
do a few hard physical things and then
you'll be like oh I yeah I quit my job
today to start something else it's fine
everybody's gonna be fine the uh other
piece of this is the internet actually
makes it so much easier right like when
you think of all the asset heavy
businesses yeah you need lots of capital
you know stuff but like today I mean I I
know two different people who have
recently quit their jobs and they quit
it because they have a sub stack yeah
like that sounds insane yeah right but
you're like wait how much money are you
making and they're like making like 100k
and one of them actually took a little
bit of a pay cut could quit his job uh
he was probably I don't know he worked
at Tech I probably make like 141.50 and
so he took a pay cut to go do it but
he's like but if I can do a hundred in
my free time I can do 300 if I focus on
it right so there's like the willingness
to take a step back to go forward yeah
uh and then the other person like they
definitely weren't making I think
they're making 125 or something now on
the sub stack like they weren't doing
that in their regular jobs so they
basically in their free time gave
themselves a promotion I love that well
and even you know even if you don't want
to go start the thing I mean and there's
a lot of founder porn out there right
but I think get on board with some way
to have some ownership to your point
somewhere where you got skin in the game
right and so maybe that is going and
joining a cool startup maybe that is
joining your team here maybe that is
getting on you know some new uh you know
business that somebody else is buying
but you're helping to fund the deals and
you're helping to find them and you ask
and you put some cash into the deals
yourself you're signing docs and so I
think that's the goal just get ownership
in some way shape or form or get some
aligned pay we're like hey if I do X Y
and Z and this happens
you know can I get compensated for that
um and and that I think then at the end
of your day at least you don't have in
your accountant on your you know
Tombstone that you were just somebody
else's accountant so two things coming
to mind one uh I don't think I've ever
said this uh before but uh what we do is
we take a portion of Revenue and we put
it into a pot and everyone who helps
create that Revenue gets a piece of it
that's cool right I love that now why
because most of the media businesses
that are like these individuals Joe
Rogan can never sell The Joe Rogan
podcast he can license it which he did
he cannot sell it because Joe Rogan
can't stop recording The Joe Rogan
podcast so what you get is uh the
incentives are weird and a lot of the
individual based media companies where
there is no equity there's no ability to
sell it that's bad for the person doing
it and it's also bad for the team uh
because like the the shitty thing to do
would be like oh give all these people
like basically Phantom Equity instead if
you do it more on like a revenue or a
profit share standpoint now all of a
sudden it's a feedback loop right
everyone on the team knows hey we're
making more or less money and like when
people are making more money they're
excited they're enthusiastic they want
to work hard if you're making less money
people like [ __ ] this sucks and you've
got the right team like let's get back
to making more money whatever so I think
that's always like people think like get
ownership has to be Equity but like you
have to be honest about like is the
equity ever going to be worth something
because I look at all and we get
approached all the time by people who
are like hey we should like do a deal
like you help me grow all my channels
and stuff I'm like I'll give you equity
and I'm like I don't you're actually
it's worthless like you couldn't pay me
to take the equity right uh but like a
revenue share I'd be interested in and
so understanding where value a cruise is
really important the second thing is uh
I have tons of young people who always
come to me and they're like have like a
job and I'm like cool what can you do
and some of them are like very
sophisticated like I could do ABCD
here's how I've done it before and
you're like got it like you're
sophisticated other people are like what
do you need done
what do you need done people I'm like uh
I need you to stop emailing me love you
like you know email me later when you've
got like a plan right uh but the other
folks when it comes to compensation I
always say the same thing I say look
there's two compensation paths here uh I
can give you a bigger guaranteed like
monthly salary and very very little
upside or I can give you a small monthly
salary and immense upside and
immediately here's some Alpha for all of
you if you pick the big monthly salary
you're the wrong person right and and I
get it I'll always talk to him about
like you know what are your monthly
expenses your family situation like like
there's other things that go into it but
the most part like the people who are
hiring they want the person who will bet
on themselves and take the upside and
all stuff because if it works the people
that I know that are really really good
running organizations they want their
people to get paid a lot when I got into
the asset management game I met somebody
who was incredibly successful at raising
assets and building Asset Management
where they managed like 30 billion
dollars like the top of the top of the
top and I said to him I said well secret
he said all the sales people drive
Ferraris
and I was like what and he was like yes
he goes I that's how I flex is that like
all of the sales people drive Ferraris I
remember being like what are you talking
about and he was like we pay them
incredibly well so the best sales people
come and work here they then go and
they're the best so they raise all the
assets which we get management fees on
and then we share an outsized percentage
of that with them compared to other
organizations and so when I show up to
somebody else's firm and all of their
sales people have Toyotas in the parking
lot I'm like you suck and your people
will never be able to work for my uh for
my organization because they're not good
enough to go drive a Ferrari I remember
just being like that is so [ __ ] up but
also like so genius oh yeah I feel like
I know this guy yeah
it was the same person but yeah he he I
always call them the cult leader um this
particular guy I
um did some stuff with and uh he does
the same thing he used to come to an the
annual meeting and he would be like I
have one goal this year and he had like
this big personality compensated I have
one goal this year
and I was like for every [ __ ] in
this room to be a millionaire and
everybody would be like
and uh and to his credit uh a bunch of
them were and like millionaires
multi-multi times over and he had really
clear aligned pay I think to your point
if if you know if you're a newbie
there's one thing you should do like
only one thing and it should be you need
to understand where profit and revenue
come from in the business that you want
to work in and how you can insert
yourself into that as a leverage point
and so if you come to me and you're like
this actually happens like one of our
video editors came to me he lives in
India he's good and uh and he was like I
want to come work full time and I was
like okay what would that look like and
he's like well I want 272 000 and I was
like come again I'm like is this are we
this currency differential what are we
talking about here he's like no no US
Dollars 272 000 I'm like Bud first of
all why and of course couldn't back it
up second like where'd you come up with
this number what do you think we make on
YouTube 272 thousands of very specific
numbers
that goes into that yeah I don't know
what whiskey didn't have a good answer
but my whole point is if he came and
said hey I want x amount of dollar I
don't know seventy thousand dollars a
year and I want it because I'm gonna do
this for our Channel and I'm gonna get
our channel to hit these goals then I I
would listen and I might not agree to
everything that he says um but I There's
real like backing behind it and so for
anybody that's working for somebody else
that's what you do you come in you
understand where the revenue is you
understand where the profit is and you
figure out how can I make this person
more money and like that I always did
that with that CEO actually that I I was
talking about when I went and started
working with him for the first time I
was like I'm working at a really big
farm I'm going to come to a smaller firm
the only reason I'm going to do that is
because I think we're going to have this
huge outcome and I slid a napkin across
the table to him and I was like if I get
us to this number then we make this
number and I want this number and he was
like yeah of course because I understood
the economics of the business it's uh
asking for raises inside of a company's
probably one of the most popular
questions that I get from people who are
like hey like I I think that I should go
get a raise at my company like how
should I uh do it and my thing is always
like whatever you ask for you have to
deliver 4 to 10x depending on the
business in that in revenue or profit
depending on on the specifics uh or it
doesn't make sense for the business so
if you're getting paid you know GC
numbers 100K and you want 150 that's a
50 increase you can't just increase the
revenue by 50k because the business
actually will lose money you need may
need to be able to show a path to can
you increase the revenue of the business
by 250 or 300 thousand dollars and then
it makes a ton of sense and what I've
always found uh sad is that like most
people don't have the ability to have uh
kind of those nuanced conversations
because they don't even understand the
business they're in this episode is
brought to you by eight sleep good sleep
is a game changer and the eight sleep
pod is the best sleep machine I sleep on
it every single night a great night of
sleep allows you to be healthier be more
arrested and have more energy throughout
the day and on the brand new eight sleep
pod 3 you can sleep as cold as 55
degrees Fahrenheit or as hot as 110
degrees Fahrenheit that's the secret of
thermoregulation better sleep better
energy get yourself in each sleep you
can go to eatsleep.com pump today to go
ahead and get 150 off your order
eightsleep.com pump not only do I sleep
on it every night it literally changed
my life and I begged the founders to let
me invest in the company eightsleep.com
go get yourself an eight sleep pod and
get a better night of sleep exactly
right if you don't understand how the
business this works then all the
conversations you're going to have with
a boss Executives whatever doesn't
really make a lot of sense because
they're like you don't get it and if you
don't get it then why would I pay you
more money why would I put you in a
position of more responsibility uh
because you're not thinking the way that
we think and therefore we gotta go find
people who do yeah I mean I I had a I
have a lot of people come to me often
because I talk about deal structuring
and deal terms a lot and they'll come to
me like one guy's pretty high up at a
large production company like name you
would know he makes a lot of money and
he was like God I'm kind of Trapped in
this I do this really cool job I make a
ton of money but one I don't know how to
negotiate something different and two
like I wouldn't know how to go buy a
business in this space and you know and
all I said to him was like well do those
first things then go learn how to buy
businesses because you're going to
understand deal structuring you're going
to understand terms you're going to
understand how a business works from a p
l and cash flow perspective and it's
actually kind of rare that people fully
understand that and people tell me all
the time like I'm in business I know how
to do all this I'm like have you ever
run a 13-week rolling cash flow in order
to make sure you understand where every
dime in a business is do you understand
zero-based expenses where like every
single dime that you have you need to
rationalize why we spend one way or the
other and what's interesting is if you
can play the game of like let me just
get really curious about business you'll
make a ton of money and then you can
apply that to negotiation really easy
because what's negotiation about when
you negotiate with your little daughter
she's not old enough for it yeah but
when she's old enough she's negotiating
she don't talk but she's a negotiable
right you like bedtime right you know
she wants to stay up right kids always
do so what do you do you work from their
leverage point and so most people don't
know how to do that with business owners
but even like I know if you've ever had
this I've had like the funniest
interactions lately in like DMS and like
Instagram or whatever as you get gotten
bigger and you start interacting with
other people that are bigger I find even
really big names on the internet are so
dense when it comes to negotiations like
one one person the other day
hope he's not listening yeah no yeah
literally like we're going back and
forth to the DMS Samuel's gonna laugh at
this story and uh and he's like uh you
know I'm like yeah cool podcast like
that whatever most recent one you did we
got some mutual friends blah blah blah
and then he comes at me with I think
he's like trying to impress me a little
bit but he's like uh yeah well if you
like the podcast if you take my
networking course you know here it is
here's a discount if you want it and I
was like I think I'm I'm doing okay I
got a few people I know I like I'm all
right right now but like thanks hey I
appreciate that and then writes back uh
not really though and I'm like huh what
do you mean he's like I don't know if
you've ever heard of this guy read
Hoffman from LinkedIn he's a billionaire
by the way and then he proceeds to tell
me about how networking works and I was
just sitting there thinking this is
fascinating like what do you think he
thinks my end goal is and what it what
is his with this conversation and this
is a very successful human if I said his
name you probably know the guy and I've
had so many interactions like this that
it's made me realize that even really
successful people have no idea how to
get what they want in negotiation so I
should I'll create a negotiation course
I'll send it back to them I'll give them
a hot discount we could take it from
there but it's super rare there's two
things that uh my wife and I have
decided are important to teach our child
not for every child but our child we
think is important one is good decision
making and the other is the ability to
negotiate uh but not like sit down and
negotiate a contract right but just
every single thing in your life comes
down to uh you're faced with the
decision can you make good decisions do
you have a good framework to understand
pros and cons risk reward uh options
like all these things that go into it
like if you're a good decision maker
you're have a higher probability of like
being okay in life yeah and then
negotiation is many times implementing
the decision that you're making and
getting what you want and a lot of
people I think look at negotiating as
the zero-sum game I win you lose yeah
instead the best negotiators actually I
win you win and that's how deals get on
and I think that that gets lost until
people start to like really really get
into doing a lot of negotiating uh I you
can almost tell immediately if a
negotiation starts off with demands and
not questions almost
categorically they don't know what
they're doing that is so true every
single time demands are not questions if
it starts out with prices instead of
questions I totally agree oh wait I want
to talk about one other thing um we need
to make sure we tell people how to make
money in a recession fully
um so there's actually we came out with
a blog post today it's on country and
thinking you can see it but it's like
seven ways to buy a business with zero
dollars I think we should Riff on some
ways to make money if you have no money
okay don't be lazy caveat but there's a
couple different ways one
during the pandemic 60 of all businesses
shut down that temporarily shut down
huge huge problem now during the next
recession probably not the same level
but there'll be some of those
every time a business shuts down I'm
sure you agree there's always value
somewhere in the business and so there's
like three types of ways I like to do
deals when a business is closing which
is happening now you're starting to see
some of it one is aqua hire right if you
have your competitors shutting down and
you run a business and you're not going
out there and trying to poach their top
talent you're crazy you should be doing
that in restaurants you should be doing
that in gyms you should be doing that in
tech companies it only happens in VC
back to tech companies two uh client
acquisition you run a local gym let's
say the Pilates studio down the way
shuts down usually nothing happens with
that business why wouldn't you go to the
owner and say instead hey I want you to
have an annuity in your business where
you continue to earn even though the
business is shut down and what if you're
all of your clients that you've spent
all this time cultivating now have a new
place to go to why don't you let me send
an email or you send an email to your
list with a couple affiliate links
anybody that transitions over to my
business will give a discount you'll own
part of them for the next two years
right so that's Client List acquisition
three is also obviously asset
acquisition so lots of people do this in
our world but not very many people think
that crime scene cleanup company I went
to yesterday when they go to a hoarding
site they take a bunch of the stuff out
of there that people want to get rid of
it and they turn around and they sell it
they also clean up those houses
sometimes and say the people who are
hoarding are like I need to clean it up
because I'm going to sell and they're
like why don't we just buy it as is
massive discount so asset position you
can do that she bought a house not too
many months ago I can't remember the
exact number uh for a dollar in Tampa
Florida and so that is totally
applicable and those are worth more than
a dollar yeah slightly it wasn't a
Barbie house so yeah and when you think
of things like Client List acquisition
how much of it is uh you acquired the
list and then you tell them hey by the
way like I'm so and so you know uh this
is what we do it's similar to this other
thing it's shutting down whatever versus
like you just add them to your email
list and like yours Off to the Races and
and just see if they click I actually
wouldn't do either I would do it based
on a success fee so if I was going to
buy somebody else's Client List because
they don't think that that has a value
they're about to just let it go away so
don't put a dollar value on it instead
say why don't I pay you for every person
that transfers over and so you can let
them control it for a period then also
you can get away from like some gdpr
like some issues if you just buy an
email list and then add them immediately
to your other list so that's how I would
do it and you don't even have to own a
business to do this you could just be a
broker right you could be like I'm Cody
I own no businesses but this restaurant
shut down I bet they have an email list
I bet they have reviews I bet they have
all this stuff why don't I go to a bunch
of restaurants in the area and see if
anybody wants to give me a percentage if
I bring this to that restaurant or
whatever type of business so three three
ideas for you guys if you want to figure
out no cash but a way to buy business I
think that email is still highly
underrated yeah right I mean so many
people are uh focused on all these like
super sexy interesting shiny things and
it's like I spend most of my time on
email yeah how big is your email now
it's big I know I remember like you told
me some time ago what it was and I was
amazed uh it's big I think for what
people would think but it's small uh in
the grand scheme of things yeah right
like we talked we were talking earlier
about Agora like I don't know how many
email subscribers they have across
Millions yeah
maybe even 100 million yeah right like
if you're doing was it a billion dollars
in Revenue
billion dollars in Revenue a year and
you just start backing it into cpms like
yes they get higher cpms it's a specific
targeted audience whatever but like I
don't know could you have a hundred
million
probably yeah right like that's like a
pretty big number uh to do a billion
dollars in revenue and so it's like okay
that's an email company right and
it'd be interesting I don't know how
much like a MailChimp makes uh in
Revenue but like does Agora or MailChimp
make more money yeah I don't know
billion dollars in revenue is a big
number and so like that's one of those
situations where like maybe actually
being the uh the service
is a Better Business than being the like
platform yeah well I think I think work
week they put out a good article
um basically talking about why so many
Creator companies were failing I mean
not to not to you know blast sub stack
but nine million in Revenue like
probably our businesses do more than sub
stack does in total revenue which is
wild then you apply their valuation
versus like what the valuation would be
on our businesses and so I think a lot
of these Creator businesses they played
a game of like I'm gonna go out to fish
and I'm just going to bring a big net
and I'm going to throw it out there and
I'm going to hope that I catch a bunch
of stuff and I think what they realized
is the best creators like it's always
the 80 20 20 rule man and so the best
creators are always going to drive the
most revenue and what you actually want
to do is optimize for those as opposed
to just have the super wide net and a
lot of these companies I think are
having that same way so I agree in
general sub stack this may be a hot take
uh I think is going to be one of the
most important companies
um context is uh I was very very uh when
the first 20 or 50 writers were ever on
there and I spent a lot of time working
with them I've even invested in the
business whole thing but one of the
things they understand that all the
other Creator companies don't is like
the initial thing is exactly correct
the network is really important there
yeah and so uh one of the features they
recently launched is uh when you sign up
for one person's email list they can
recommend other people's emails yeah and
so now some of these people 50 to 70
percent of all of their growth is coming
from this like recommendation Network
that they've created yeah so like I I
one of the things that people always
forget is like creating content on the
internet there are people who like the
content you that does not mean you will
be successful in building a business you
still have to be an entrepreneur you
just have to Market you still have to
understand how to negotiate deals you
still have to do all these things
that just creating content doesn't cover
so if they can help you get more
subscribers like that's pretty valuable
but then what they've started to do is
then they've started to add other
features some of them are public some of
them are that they're testing and what
you start to realize is like oh like
they're just going to build like the
Salesforce equivalent for these creators
in a way where they just say look if you
want ad Revenue like there's all these
other platforms but we're going to be
the dominant player for subscription
Revenue yeah and you look at it and
you're like okay that's like a very
clear thesis will it work still
questionable yeah um but my thought
process is that the consumer Behavior
has now officially changed do we want to
guess how many subscriptions you and I
both have like a lot it'd be
embarrassing don't do it my mom's gonna
panic I I don't know yeah uh and uh I
have a friend
um her husband always jokes with me uh
and her that uh he just like shows up at
uh their house and like [ __ ] just shows
up and he's like what is this and she's
like oh it's a subscription like
whatever and he's like you didn't even
know this was coming like you literally
have so many subscriptions I'm not that
bad but like I've got got enough and
when you look at them it's like Oh My
Consumer Behavior changed I now do not
think twice whether it is a one-time
purchase or a subscription purchase
because I almost expect these businesses
all to move to subscription and so
consumer Behavior changes then guess
what's going to happen is like it's
going to change in these other markets
as well and so like people subscribing
to a sub stack doesn't feel any
different than subscribing to all the
other subscription Services yeah yeah I
think it'll be interesting I mean I
believe in the infrastructure of the
Creator economy to a certain extent
because I invested in we're competitors
actually it turns out I invested in
beehive oh yeah yeah
um so they were the guys that were
behind the morning Bruce infrastructure
and you know I think there's room in
this space for lots of different models
just like everywhere else and in fact I
think there's not enough tools for this
new economy yet so I think it's awesome
but it's all just small businesses like
that that's the other thing is all the
creators are just the equivalent of the
small medium-sized businesses yeah 50 of
jobs in America come from smbs yeah and
now we are just watching all those young
people who would have taken over the
Main Street store right or created a
business in their local Town they're not
doing it on the internet which is better
for them yep and it probably ends up
actually contributing more to society
yeah I mean you said something earlier
which I totally agree with that I think
is really important at some point maybe
soon nobody's going to care about you or
me right like intention and attention on
the internet that do not stay forever
nobody stays relevant forever it's just
not reasonable to think that I'm gonna
get a few more wrinkles totally
irrelevant right
um
so it's like fine you could have like a
hole in your face it'd be fine
um but anyway so um the the interesting
part I think is that for anybody who's a
Creator on the internet to your point
you better have something else that
isn't just your face and your time tied
to it because imagine you get sick and
you can't write that sub step for six
months what happens do you have a
business or do you have a job you know
let's imagine that nobody cares about
the topic you're talking about I mean we
saw this in crypto how many people had
low value crypto content that was
largely resharing and hype men and have
gone away they're irrelevant now now if
during that period they had also
invested in a bunch of businesses they
had made really smart connections maybe
they had built a business that was
infrastructure and not hyper speculation
cool then that attention was well uh
deserved and will continue on but that's
one thing I think a lot of people are
not preparing for it's also why I will
never be on one platform like you can
have a newsletter that's awesome but I
think you better also have some social
uh channels behind you and you know
contrain thinking our business doesn't
have my name on it now my face is all
over everything but there's a reason
it's called contrarian thinking because
I'm going to have varying businesses
that are around it we already do and
then my employees will be able to have
equity in multiple lines that could
actually sell as opposed to you know the
one overarching Cody Sanchez which I'm
never going to sell my name or likeness
unless you know it's it's got a billion
trillionaire
the uh the one other thing I keep coming
back to to is this idea of a burnout I
think a lot of especially young people
um they're not ready like there's going
to be a tsunami of burnout so all these
people like I'm like in the Creator
economy I'm a Creator I'm like you are
literally two years away from just being
like holy [ __ ] this sucks and so my
warning to all of them is like build the
infrastructure yeah right like I can't
tell you how many people I know who uh
they're like I record my podcast I edit
my podcast I write my newsletter I do
all my tweets I do like all the stuff
and I'm like that sounds awesome
but like guess what I don't edit the
podcast I don't edit the video right and
like what you what what is this saying
like um uh to go fast go alone to go
further go together right and so what
you do is like I get it in the beginning
like yes you do have to do some of that
stuff but uh you have to think about it
like a business and building
infrastructure and systems and processes
and all this or you and your team will
just one day be like [ __ ] it like we're
out I actually have two Consultants
right now that had really one had a huge
YouTube channel 900 000 subscribers pay
now works for me because he was tired he
didn't want to build any more videos It
Wasn't interesting to him he just lost
all of his creative juices on it he did
pretty good had a couple good months and
was like I'm I'm out and now he really
likes what he's doing because he
consults he does it when he wants he
lives in Mexico City he's got a good
good thing going
um and I have another one that does that
for me on the content side and so I
think you're exactly right people too
often listen to these woo-woo you know
feather wearing gurus talk about passion
and profits and bring them both together
and then you'll be happy it's a business
man some days you're gonna have to do a
Excel spreadsheet as a Creator and like
you're not gonna like it another day
you're going to get a lawsuit it's gonna
suck and so you know this idea of like I
have to follow my passion like yes you
want to love what you do but like find
the passion in the things that you do I
don't think every day anybody on this
existence of a planet loves what they do
every single second do you want to know
uh something sad that we can end on yeah
that's sad because it's great for you
and I but uh I gotta admit that I do
this sometimes
especially younger people like mid-20s
that want to do this I'm like you know
you should do
you should hang out with me for a day
and about halfway through the dance how
how's it going like what do you think so
far and like they're like it's cool like
whatever and at the end of the day I say
by the way you'll never [ __ ] catch me
right like you never will because you're
not willing to do this like I'm on year
like six or seven you haven't even
started yet and like I just did more
work this week than you're gonna do all
uh or I did more work today than you did
all week and part of it is like there's
only a few people who have like gone
through that and seen it and then they
still want to do it so it's like if
you're gonna quit like just don't start
oh yeah but the people who get through
the filter then I'm like oh you're gonna
do this forever yeah like or you're
gonna do it for a very very long time
because like you actually understand
what it's going to take to be able to
build this and if you're still willing
to like you know run gung-ho up the
mountain like all right you got a shot
like good luck yeah I was editing the
newsletter at 12 a.m last night like
still you know and you know it was just
I didn't like what it is who it's time
for editing just write it and send it
yeah that's how I do it well you know
actually it's interesting because I
remember like back in the day when you
were first like really rolling I was
like this [ __ ] he does a Daily
Show and all the content he does and
Twitter like I thought you were just
licking the walls that were filled with
coach like how did you how did you do
that and like what's your seat because
your stamina level's wild yeah I enjoy
it yeah like I I I enjoyed less some of
the like I call it intellectual Combat
on Twitter oh yeah
I used to go to war I used to love it
I'd be like listen you want to go like
I'll go with the best of them and like
it only takes two or three back and
forth before like here comes the kill
shot right uh but I think now like that
stuff's less interesting to me um uh I
have a daughter right like sometimes I'm
like I'm not gonna say that but one day
she's gonna read that on the internet
and be like Dad you're an [ __ ]
um so like I I think I've like become
lessons for that part but the part that
I do enjoy is like if you said to me
like what would I do all day right like
it
it is I would talk to interesting people
yeah I would like think which really
writing is just thinking and you have to
just kind of clarify it uh I would read
and then uh I would like think about or
work on business stuff like that's what
I do every day yeah right and the other
thing um I think people are surprised by
like I pretty much read like a book a
week now yeah and they're like how do
you do that I'm like well it's not a
chore right it was a chore I wouldn't
read it all but I find things that I
think are interesting which I think I
can learn from and then like it's not
that hard if a book is 300 350 Pages
like Read 50 pages a day yeah whatever I
mean sometimes I do I like think to
myself I'm like can you believe we get
paid for this you know like when when I
was doing you know the investment
banking and and Wall Street stuff and
doing 12-hour days and miserable and now
people are like oh man we gotta I gotta
film you know like seven or eight tick
tocks today I'm like I think we're gonna
make it we're gonna make it like this is
the worst that you're gonna throw at me
you know no problem but it also uh it
drastically reduced the a barrier to
entry on content in a way that like if
anyone was interested in doing this you
used to have to want to be a movie star
or have to want to go be like a TV
anchor that was basically the path right
um and now what we did is we basically
compressed an entire TV studio into a
phone and somebody can use this and you
know news flash they are way more
popular than uh most of the movie stars
and they're way more popular than most
of the TV anchors and they do it with a
phone and it's because the quality of
the information is better yeah and like
I think that goes back to this idea of
everyone's like oh I don't know how to
do uh what they're doing I'm like no
just do the thing that nobody else can
do like do the thing you can do and
that's where the audience is ah yeah 100
and also you know we're not like spring
chickens anymore exactly so you know if
you want to crush it on the internet and
you're you know 12 15 17 20. you're just
gonna get it faster than us you know pop
and I gonna be over here like trying to
fix the lighting he's gonna have his
glasses on you know and like you guys
are just going to move faster and so if
we can help you by saying all right we
learned a few things the couple things
we learned are like understand the
language of money which is deal making
and finance because no matter what
business you do whether the business is
tick-tocking or makeuping or whatever it
is you got to understand this language
if you don't speak the language it
doesn't matter and then you got to
understand how do you negotiate and then
you've got to understand a couple of
things like yourself like that stuff
inside of you what do I really like
doing what makes me happy paired with
what am I good at you know five two
probably not gonna be a basketball
player let's be a little honest and then
you you pair that with the fact that you
guys have Tech at your fingertips in a
way that we never did it's amazing no
better time to be alive don't believe
anybody that says otherwise and even if
we come into a really awful recession
which I think is a travesty how this all
has been dealt with and where we've come
I think we have a lot of similar views
on that but you know the world that
you're coming into right now for people
that don't have debt hangovers and
investment hangovers which if you're
young you probably don't you're coming
in really fresh and in this world that
means even if you don't have a ton of
cash you aren't negative cash and so you
should be looking at this environment
like man now is the time to lean in it's
the time to build it's the time to buy
something it's the time to partner with
somebody to buy something and no better
time right now than to do it and then
pair it with content get the cash figure
out the business model pair it with some
sort of content and I think you know
next step you got your your ass your PE
your titties just like Kim Kardashian up
there and I could take it that's a great
place to end where can we send people to
find you on the internet
contrarianthinking.com probably the best
newsletter and I'm Cody Sanchez on all
the socials awesome thank you we will
definitely do this again that is awesome
man